march is nutrition month and you don't
have to overhaul your diet completely
to eat healthier and feel your best
registered dietitian
mia sin shares three simple nutrition
tips that anyone can follow plus some
delicious recipes
that you can make at home hey las vegas
now it's national nutrition month and
you don't have to overhaul your diet
completely
to eat healthier and feel your best
today i have three simple nutrition tips
plus some recipes that you can make at
home my first tip is to snack smarter
wonderful pistachios are what i call a
snack with staying power because one
serving provides six grams of
plant-based protein
and three grams of filling fiber plus
nearly ninety percent of the fats found
in pistachios are the better for you
mono and polyunsaturated type so you get
a protein fiber fat trio that may help
keep you fuller longer pair with a piece
of fruit or whole grain crackers to
build a balanced snack
my next nutrition tip is to rethink your
beverages
replace sugar sweetened beverages with
nutrient-dense options like florida
orange juice which contributes vitamins
minerals and antioxidants including
folate potassium and vitamin c
a common misconception about orange
juice is that it's jam-packed with added
sugars
in truth 100 orange juice doesn't
contain any added sugar
the sweetness you taste comes from the
naturally occurring sugars that develop
as oranges grow
making it a nutritious replacement for
sugar sweetened beverages
add it to baked goods smoothies or
homemade salad dressings for a boost of
nutrition
and to help reach your daily fruit
intake recommendation
smoothies are another nutritious
beverage option and an easy way to help
you meet your recommended five servings
of fruits and veggies for the day
to a blender add frozen mango and
pineapple a half cup of greek yogurt
one cup of 100 orange juice and one
teaspoon of icelandic wild fish oil
which adds omega-3 fats important for
brain and heart health plus
ostaxanthin a powerful antioxidant found
in seafood
important for brain eye skin and immune
health if you aren't a seafood fan this
is a good alternative that allows you to
reap the benefits of omega-3 fats in a
clean tasting liquefied form that you
can add to smoothies or recipes
you can find it on amazon my last
nutrition tip is to satisfy sweet
cravings with desserts with benefits
try these melt in your mouth sweet
potato collagen brownies add one cooked
sweet potato to a food processor with a
third cup of nut butter
three tablespoons of maple syrup a
fourth cup of cacao powder and one scoop
of sparkle wellness skin boost plus
varisol collagen powder which comes in
unflavored and flavored varieties like
orange and tropical
some research suggests that taking
collagen daily may help
improve skin appearance and elasticity
while minimizing unwanted signs of aging
bake in a lined bread pan for 20 minutes
at 350 degrees fahrenheit
i hope you enjoyed these recipes and
tips you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas and nutrition tips
daily
desserts with benefits okay we always
love your tips thank you mia